alors mon invité suivant été champion
olympique atlanta en 1996 ainsi lé nez
il a terminé au pied du podium
pourtant tout le monde parle de lui
voici jalal noir
bon ça va djamel bien alors djamel
bouras des médailles d'or atlanta on l'a
dit retour triomphal en france après
atlanta vous êtes un peu à l'époque le
symbole zidane est ce que de
l'intégration du regard délavé lui la
france est formidable avec des beurs qui
gagne au foot et qui gagne au au judo et
puis en 90 elle vous êtes contrôlés
positifs à la nandrolone est suspendu un
an
mais le doute subsiste malgré tout parce
que vous d'abord voulu nier et le doute
subsiste alors 11
il ya des plusieurs hypothèses qui sont
échafaudés à ce moment là est-ce que
vous secret était naturellement de la
nandrolone de ce qu'il faut savoir quand
même que tout ça c'est des mesures sur
cinq millionième de gramme
deuxième hypothèse la fiabilité des
mesures parce que c'est vrai qu'en cinq
millionième de gramme c'est pas tout les
balances qui peuvent le mesurer et puis
la deuxième solution c'est le produit
vous auriez pris un produit non
interdite qui aurait les mêmes effets
dans les contrôles que la nand rôle
enfin bon en tous les cas on n'a jamais
su s'estimant proposé de dire c'est ce
qu'ils ont proposé des oui et j'ai
refusé
mais bon j'aimerais bien voir le la même
les même jusqu'à lui virenque
ouais parce que ça faisait deux ans
qu'il disait qu'il était innocent ouais
et là il a balancé leur disant qu'ils
avaient pris même si j'essaie juge comme
il ya dix ans l'air très compétent ouais
donc moi je veux bien avoir ces juges là
pour qu'il me juge et moi je signe un
papier aujourd'hui que si demain je dis
que j'ai pris s'il arrive à trouver
quelque chose je fais une signe pour
aller pour faire 15 ans de prison
oui tiens vous vous dites que le virage
ça fait plusieurs années qu'il nie bon
un jour il avoue il va prendre six mois
vous vous dites moi j'ai toujours aimé
les ondes en un an ferme voilà donc 16
mois sans compétition vous êtes plein
trouve que c'est vrai retrouvez les en
colombie un peu de partout pour aller
faire des dons de passer devant les
donjons les jurés et j'ai perdu pas mal
d'argent mais c'est pas grave ça c'est
mon chemin là dans la vérité j'essaye
mais j'aimerais bien avoir ce mur et je
l'aï j'appelle ce juré venez chercher de
la vérité vous allez savoir j'ai rien et
vous dit si je suis coupable je suis
prêt à prendre 15 ans 15 ans et tout le
bien que je vous le donne ouais je suis
devant vous pas de problème
alors oui donc en 99 des suspendus par
la fédération internationale dont quinze
mois loin des tatamis vous retournez
vous revenez dans le judo avec des
résultats un peu en dents de scie et à
sydney vous partez à sydney alors vous
étiez dans quel état d'esprit parce que
moi j'ai lu une déclaration que j'avais
fait je crois c'est dans les kivu dit en
parlant de sydney je ne suis pas venu
défendre un titre olympique c'est pas
comme le championnat du monde où la boxe
les jo ont en effet une fois dans sa vie
puis moi j'ai gagné le titre et c'est
pour toujours
c'est dans l'équipe du 19 septembre hier
que vous en faites
est-ce qu'on peut pas vous reprocher
finalement les traits dessinés en disant
moi j'ai été champion olympique une fois
c'est formidable après tout maintenant
c'est du bonus quoi parce que toute
façon j'ai été champion olympique est ce
que vous n'êtes pas parti à signer en
visant que le vrai combat c'était celui
d'atlanta et que sydney c'était du bonus
mais c'était pas fondamental pour vous
non parce que si c'est ça j'arrête je
suis plus motivé
ouais je crois que l'on fût ce avec ce
qui s'est passé j'avais une autre
motivation
donc j'avais envie de gagner mais bon il
y avait des jeux comme j'ai eu pas mal
de problèmes et puis comme j'ai des
problèmes avec l'arbitrage depuis deux
ans vous dites avoir été meilleur à
sydney
qu'à atlanta et pourtant vous avez perdu
j'étais le meilleur
c'est à dire que les combats que je fais
là bas qui était beaucoup moins un peu
moins dur à atlanta que j'ai gagné de
justesse alors que là les combats j'ai
commencé par un premier combat qui
aurait pu être une finale déjà contre
ahrens le landais et que je me les
arbitrages étaient contre moi et j'ai
gagné quand même par ippon c'est à dire
y penser à red arrêt du combat et les
trois premiers combats
je les ai gagnés par ippon j'avais un
tirage très dans mon quart de finale
c'était le quart de finale le plus dur
et je suis arrivé en demi finale contre
le japonais s'était tu dis que tu
méritais de monter sur le podium
c'est à dire qu'en demi finale si je
gagne le championnat ouais donc voilà je
prends le coréen de le coréen du nord en
finale que j'ai battu autant à paris
alors là non maintenant mais on est au
coeur du problème donc vous dites et
c'est important parce que c'est pas moi
qui dis ça vous n'êtes pas le seul à le
dire
vous dites depuis c'est la faute des
arbitres si j'ai pas été sur le podium à
sydney depuis la nandrolone je suis plus
jugé comme les autres et là j'ai relevé
un certain nombre d'avis de gens
importants qu'ils disent la même chose
que vous donc là ça pose vraiment
problème et ça mérite qu'on s'y
intéresse
il ya jean luc rougé qui est directeur
de la fédé qui dit ça mérite pas cessé
c'est une sanction contre contre bouras
fabien canu qui est directeur technique
national qui dit on ne veut pas qu'ils
gagnent donc les mecs c'est pas des
n'importe qui un il ya michel vial qui
est chef de la mission française aux jo
de sydney qui dit c'est malhonnête
il a payé et on veut quand même
continuer à le pousser dehors
voilà à quoi donc qu'il ya quand même un
service que je rends vous savez je
regardais les arbitres et baisse est un
peu tous la tête
je dois dire écoutez maintenant si c'est
ça que vous voulez je vais arrêter voilà
donc vous aujourd'hui non seulement vous
mais encore si vous le disiez on
pourrait dire il est parano il n'a pas
gagné il cherche des excuses mais je
trouve quand même que les sommités du
judo dans ce pays
les sommités officiels disent en fait
c'est vrai djamel bouras n'est pas jugée
comme il devrait être jugé t on veut le
virer quoi déjà un championnat d'europe
ou trois quatre mois avant je me suis
fait voler contre le biélorusse les
arbitres ont reconnu dont ils sont venus
une excuse excusez moi on sait on
s'excuse jamais complète à définir
même maintenant six excuses n'ont pas
refaire légers au premier âge et été
coulé par un biélorusse
le fait que vous revendiquez votre
islamisme est ce que vous pensez pas que
ça peut aussi jouer contre vous qu'est
ce que ça veut dire islamise non mais
vous êtes musulman vous le revendiquez
moi je suis catholique je me revendique
sais pas jouer des tours mais les gros
titres
les bronchites médiatique français
lorsque je vois ça quand on parle
d'islamisme c'est un peu avec
l'intégrisme
oui lorsqu'on est de confession
musulmane lorsqu'on est français de
confession musulmane et qu'on dédie sa
médaille d'or parce qu'elle est injuste
il ya eu des injustices cette année-là
envers les musulmans
et donc j'ai été touché bon je vois
qu'ils avaient des oppresseurs et des
opprimés et que ya pas de justice qui se
faisait massacrer parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de pétrole a gagné n'y a rien du
tout c'est normal que je dédie un peu
mes médailles d'or ne peuvent jamais eu
une pensée à eux savez je ne regarde pas
du tout si c'était à refaire je l'aurais
fait alors j'ai reçu beaucoup de mails
la suite de l'intervention dans
l'émission de michel boujenah d'abord
pour me dire ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que michel boujenah a été invité
ici pour parler de son spectacle est
vite arrivé un peu cassée et d'une panne
d'électricité s'est assis là il nous a
parlé de son spectacle et ce n'était pas
du tout prévu que michel boujenah
s'exprime sur le problème du
moyen-orient sur le conflit israélo
arabe
il a dit son sa position à lui dans
l'émission et j'ai reçu beaucoup
beaucoup du mail me disant si la france
veut montrer sa la véritable neutralité
française dans le conflit du
moyen-orient
il faut que vous invite chez la semaine
prochaine quelqu'un qui est musulman
alors je profite de votre présence ici
djamel bouras pour vous demander si vous
avez vu le l'intervention de boujenah
mais pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu on va la
regarder
quand je vois des enfants en première
ligne avec derrière eux des palestiniens
armés et devant ed
dernière mais et que je vois les enfants
milieu avec les pierres jeudi qui sont
les parents de ces enfants qui ont 9 10
ans pour qui les laisse sortir
comment un père peut laisser son fils de
neuf ou dix ans sortir pour jeter des
pierres
alors qui sait ce qu'ils risquent le
soldat qui en face il a 18 ans qu'est ce
que voulez qu'il fasse
vous croyez qu'il va pas porté toute sa
vie la mort de l'enfant
vous croyez que toute sa vie va pas le
regretter c'est trop simple
ce qui se passe en france aujourd'hui et
la désinformation qui a hué
extraordinaire gallésie de dire informer
nous s'est il n'ya pas longtemps il ya
eu 3 3 disent rien qui ont été lynchées
lyncher ça veut dire c'est pas je me
bats avec toi et je te tue
ça veut dire je te prends je tâche et je
te pend c'est pas la même chose il faut
les jeux ce que je ressens aujourd'hui
par rapport à ce qui se passe en france
sur les synagogues qui ont été brûlés
sur toute la résurgence de cette
violence qui vient en france
je pense que la presse et les médias ont
une grande responsabilité
vous avez un pouvoir un pouvoir qui est
dangereux qu'il faut manipuler avec
beaucoup de délicatesse et beaucoup
d'intelligence
je crois qu'il ya une légitimité il ya
quelque chose qui a légitimé cette
violence chez les jeunes ici en france
qui est illogique qui est folle il ya
beaucoup de victimes dans cette histoire
chez les palestiniens et chez les
isréliens faut pas l'oublier quand j'ai
vu un palestinien la télé il ya deux
jours qui a perdu un fils ça me fait de
la peine de voir un homme père de son
fils croyez moi j'ai un jeune enfant je
sais ce que c'est il qu'est ce qu'il a
dit là dit j'en ai encore quatre à
sacrifier john encore car il n'a pas dit
je vais aller me battre mois il a dit
j'ai encore quatre à sacrifier voilà
c'était donc michel boujenah dans la
dernière émission de tout le monde en
parle donc comme je lé deal venait pour
parler de son spectacle à un moment la
conversation a eu lieu là dessus
effectivement beaucoup de gens m'ont dit
pourquoi on donne pas la parole à ceux
qui sont en face ben voilà vous pouvez
vous exprimer
djamel bouras je crois que le point le
plus important du discours de michel
boujenah c'est de dire c'est pas bien
d'envoyer des enfants quoi parce que
effectivement c'est jouer à travers la
télévision entre les médias s'est joué à
travers là
sur la sensibilité des gens mais je
pense qu'il est un peu pas mal de
d'ignorance de sa part premièrement et
j'aimerais enlever des amalgames
quand il parle de médias déjà on va voir
tout de suite sur le point aujourd'hui
en fin de cette semaine
qu'est ce que veut dire pour moi je ne
comprends pas un mois je suis un peu
bête donc les juifs français
les arabes c'est à dire que moi je suis
quoi arabe où je suis français pourtant
je combats pour la france je m'en
passerai donc il ya beaucoup de français
en plus s'il faut savoir que quand on
dit antisémite
les arabes sont des sémites aussi nos
missions plus antisioniste antisémite
voulait dire voilà ça fait donc c'est
déjà il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
différents n'arrête pas de faire des
amalgames seront entre les arabes les
musulmans et des arabes qui sont
chrétiens et des arbres qui sont hâtés
exécrable qui sont etc etc
donc ça c'est une chose très importante
ensuite je vais répondre un peu je vais
essayer de répondre un peu à boujenah je
crois qu'il a eu des problèmes un peu
avec son spectacle parce qu'il n'a dit
autre chose et déjà il ya deux semaines
sur le jdd
j'étais surpris un peu subi qu'un c'est
super ce qu'il a dit il est que sharon
c'était un [ __ ] presse etc etc et
dates de semaine après échange de
discours
sachant que ça rentre c'est vraiment à
l'emploi il faut pas vous ne faut pas
oublier les massacres qu'ils affaires au
liban la sabra et chatila avec 1500
morts etc etc
un bon en plus ce qu'il faut le problème
d'abord israël sait qu'il ya des
résolutions par l'onu ont été faites
salle de la halle la résolution de 67 je
crois qu'elle à 2 242 ils sont dans des
territoires occupés il devrait partir
c'est l'onu qui a décidé ça il ne part
pas ensuite on part son nom quand il
parle des enfants
de quel enfant et par lequel enfants il
parle des enfants mais maintenant qu'ils
sont noyés selon lui un char non mais
des enfants nés ici avec leur chocolat
lors pas un seul le croissant et c'est
là nintendo etc
des gens qui sont nés dans la guerre
convient leurs pairs muller père mourir
ils ont même plus de père pour le redis
reste ici mais ils ont plus de mer ils
mangent pas c'est une catastrophe
il faut aller voir moi je le prends au
mot moi je suis aujourd'hui je suis là
pareil je suis pas là à faire le
justicier de la terre 1
mais il ya des choses qui me révolte
donc moi je le prends
moi boujenah on va prendre une caméra et
demain je pars a vécu là bas on va
filmer
comment vit israël comment s israël et
on va filmer comment vivent les
palestiniens et je crois que cette
vérité va faire beaucoup de mal parce
que je vous assure que le sais j'en
souffre on croyait qu'il serait pas
mieux à notre place en train de jouer en
train de faire en train de sortir avec
des petites filles en train de s'amuser
comme tout le monde
non ils sont en train a emprunté et
quand on me dit mais l'enfant oui mais
l'enfant croyait que le jeune quand ils
les massacrent les trois soldats qui ont
été massacrés mais c'est des soldats et
quand on me dit se sont trompés de
terrain en tant que guerre tu vas te
tromper terrain tu te retrouve chez les
palestiniens
mais ça fout la raconter sa vie à des
enfants ou des jeunes n'est pas tout le
monde quand même il faut pas nous
prendre pour des cons savez israël il ya
pas que des juifs et des arabes
donc il est quoi exactement
il est tunisien il est français ciné
israël je sais pas moi il faudrait
qu'ils m'expliquent un peu une personne
comme une ré comme assia ce qui est ce
qu il a chanté une chanson sur le
malheur à celui qui qui qui touche un
enfant
malheur à celui qui touche un enfant
veut bien dire ce que ça veut dire qu'il
soit noir ou blanc et c'est alors et
quand tu le vois défiler sur les
champs-elysées pour avec des drapeaux je
sais pas si c'était lui ou pas ma vie
des drapeaux et des sionistes on est
fiers etc
et tu dois après d'irm alors c'était
quoi c'est un business et que moi je les
vis j'étais avec lui quand j'étais
invité par le comme j'ai une double
culture j'étais invité par le président
bouteflika et je les ai vus en train de
pleurer et pourra pas nier ça je l'aï vu
en train de pleurer devant boudant
bouteflika en train de dire au chemin
mon pays de l'algérie je suis fier je
suis fier je veux rentrer là bas etc
il a fait une chanson s&m ricome
atteindrait comme un ca je me dis mais
attend dans ma tête je vous dis donc
c'est quoi ce jeu sans quoi c'est quoi
comme citoyen c'est quoi comme ils sont
algériens ils sont français ils sont
israéliens c'est quoi le truc moment
donné je crois que on est tous pour la
paix moi je suis le premier à être pour
la paix pour l'amour pour tous ces mots
là qui nous entourent qu'on a envie de
2 2 pour lesquelles on a envie de vibrer
moi je suis un des premiers mois je suis
contre les gens qui brûlent des
synagogues mais déjà il faut être sûr
que ce soit des français d'origine
maghrébine etc avant de dénoncer quoi
que ce soit quelle est votre position il
avait vite vol là dessus bah moi on en
parlait tout à l'heure
moi je crois que immigrés pour parler
des les français d'origine arabe qui
sont musulmans mais qui sont français ou
des juifs français pour moi et me grey
s'est pas changer de pays
c'est changer l'histoire l'idée quand
même 2 quand on est français juifs
français arabe français on est français
moi je me souviens d'avoir inauguré la
mosquée de lyon avec charles pasqua
quand ils étaient mises à l'intérieur
j'ai un petit peu puisque elle a
participé à la rédaction du discours qui
d'une habitation des mosquées millions
je m'en souviens bien et et c'était ça
l'idée c'était le le même sang versé
pour la même patrie au fond l'a été par
des gens d'origines très différentes et
au fond c'est pour les émigrés c'est
changer d'histoire
si vous êtes français vous êtes français
devait d origine m algérienne doit être
tunisiennes peuvent être alors ce qui me
concerne j'en ai des croates j'en ai les
russes j'en ai j'en ai j'en ai d'autres
encore
mais mon histoire elle commence avec
l'histoire de france justement
l'intégrer si on prend l'exemple de
l'irak
lorsque en 91 le 17 janvier ils ont mis
un ultimatum ce jour là ils ont dit
voilà il ya une résolution vous devez
partir du koweit
non on n'est pas d'accord le monde
entier étaient contrôlés ont bombardé et
je vous expliquais un truc si vous ne
savez pas il ya 7000 enfants par mois
qui mord encore là ils sont en train de
se faire bombarder encore et personne ne
veut 7000 7000 enfants par mois qui mord
et je vous explique anne au dessus si
vous savez pas ils vendent leurs organes
pour manger ça une chose qu'on sait
jamais mais ça fait dix ans qu'ils sont
quand on leur donne pas à manger ils ont
même pas le droit de d'avoir des crayons
à papier parce qu'ils ont peur s'ils
vont construire de larmes des armements
chimiques etc etc
c'est une catastrophe c'est ce que vous
dites djamel bouras et lorsque l'irak au
koweït ne respecte pas une décision de
l'onu
le monde entier se coalisent
pour faire respecter les décisions de
l'onu sur sur israël la palestine ya une
décision de l'onu que la résolution de
son 49 chiffres et vous dites que
personne se coalisent pour la faire
respecter la soeur parce que israël est
protégé par le grand patron du monde est
le grand patron du monde sait les états
unis et est subventionné par les états
unis
les galas bémol c'est exact ça c'est
tout accès aux grands patrons là où se
trouve dans cette histoire encore qu'il
est absurde c'est que tout le monde au
début de cette histoire
lorsque sharon est allé sur l'esplanade
je sais pas ce qu'il allait faire ce
jour là l anfr peut-être sa prière elle
était avec 100 avec 100 l'est devenu
avec sans supporters ce live earth c'est
pas des supporters c'est des snipers
enfin enfin bref il est venu je passe
les gens tout le monde a dit ils ont
tort
la seule le seul état qui s'est abstenu
c'est quand même les américains bien je
rappelle le titre de votre livre combat
vers la lumière vous étiez venu à
l'époque où c'était sorti
là